Ellen DeGeneres and wife Portia de Rossi  forced to evacuate California home due  to wildfires on Sunday the talk show  host revealed she had to evacuate her  home due to the Thomas fire one of many  wildfires currently burning in Southern  California damaging and destroying  thousands of properties in its wake  Ellen tweeted quote our house is under  threat of being burned we just had to  evacuate our pets the couple who have  several cats and dogs bought the  eighteen point six million dollar  beachfront home in Carpinteria near  Santa Barbara in October the Emmy winner  added quote I'm proud to be a part of  this community  I'm sending lots of love and gratitude  to the fire department and Sheriff's  thank you all  [Music]  you